coco from ghana a classic
african eu trade product many african
countries export their raw materials
like cocoa
unprocessed value is added further down
the supply line
and that's where the money is made in
most cases the processing
and the profit taking happens outside
africa
to change this and help ghana reap
higher profits the european union wants
to strengthen trade relations with the
country
a member of the african caribbean and
pacific group of states
the eu wants to establish more
public-private partnerships to help
build better infrastructure in the
region
the bloc also wants to spend more money
on clean energy like solar
power as well as education
apprenticeships and job opportunities
the new acp eu agreement aims to help
people in remote areas get access to
electricity as well as the internet
a main pillar for a better education
system
their goal is to help poorer countries
combat root causes of migration
in return the acp countries agree to a
political demand of the eu
they will take back economic refugees
from eu countries
without preconditions the new deal was
more than two years in the making our
reporter marina strauss asked both sides
how they eventually reached agreement
the european union always stressed that
it now wants an equal partnership with
africa
and also the caribbean and pacific
states do you think
this idea is indeed reflected in the new
agreement
yes i think it is first and foremost
it's important to note that we approach
these discussions
i will tell you the truth at times
during the negotiations
frustrations arose around who was
superior
who was giving and who was receiving
but i have to say that we worked in a
truly constructive spirit with the
commissioner
and all her team
the new agreement reads improving
cooperation on return and readmission of
irregular migrants
is a crucial element of the new
agreement
this is a very important issue for the
european union
what do you expect from the eu when it
comes to migration
europe
now we on the african continent are
worried because we're seeing our young
people leave
to go to the european eldorado
more than 22 000 of them have died in
the ocean
we cannot be proud of this as ruling
politicians
on the contrary we are ashamed
so the solution we have found for now on
migration could please some
and not others in any case we need to be
able to identify migrants
sometimes a person may be arrested whom
we cannot identify
from the eu side are you happy with this
solution
you found there is legal migration which
is also represented
but also return and readmission and we
are very satisfied because now we
really have a legal framework
for returns and readmissions
so uh this is a this is a really
step forward from the european union
perspective and and now of course it's
important that we are able to implement
this new agreement
thank you very much to both of you merci
i would do thank you